all right it looks like we're now live
for
april's ama that's ask me anything
session i don't see any questions yet so
i'll just tell you a little bit about uh
what's going on here in the mke that's
milwaukee so it's officially spring and
we have
snowfall today that's been going on
since uh yesterday and it's kind of a
winter wonderland here even though we're
officially in spring which is good to
see because we we need the precipitation
and it's always nice to see the city
covered in
snow so
people can fire away with their
questions i'm not seeing anything
in the chat
in the top chat oh there we go
let me see if i can toggle there very
good
so
marcus says why do some people like
giannis varufucus talk about giving
ukraine 100 billion in erasing their
debt if we're really truly supporting
ukraine sounds nice but what does that
mean why can't we do that i don't know i
mean that's that's not really uh an
issue i'm particularly
concerned with um and why do people talk
about anything we live in a media
saturated environment where any any idea
is going to get put out there by
somebody and um you know not really a
thing for
for me to opine about i'm just happy to
see that that ukraine is holding well
against the uh
seems to be fairly rotten russian
military so
zeno uh took a break from being in time
we had to read heidegger for an
aesthetics class that i'm taking well
okay
i mean you take breaks from
all sorts of people all the time and uh
that's perfectly
fine to do i mean
you've all heard me say this over and
over again any
philosopher any
uh work of philosophy that's really
worth reading you're gonna you're gonna
read multiple times you know so it's not
like you
have to follow this very defined
curriculum where you begin at the
beginning and you end at the end you
know it's okay to read around
uh in various ways mark says hi greg hi
everyone hope you're all keeping well
yeah it's cold here in milwaukee cold
enough to snow like i was saying but
i've got some nice coffee
from stone creek one of our local
roasters
and
one of my favorite places to go if
you're ever here in milwaukee there's a
good chance you can find me at the
factory cafe and uh yeah we're ready to
to go message what don't you like about
merlot ponte where does he fall short
and what other philosopher do you agree
with in terms of epistemology well i
don't worry about marilyn ponting in
terms of epistemology i'm interested
he's you know he's okay um
i think this is the wrong sort of
approach to take mastercare has got a
history with this
you know way asking why mariloponte
ponti's not in my
top 10 philosophers or top 20
philosophers on that video that i had
and you know the simple answer to that
is there are literally hundreds of
people who didn't make it into the top
10 or top 20 and that's not necessarily
anything wrong with them it's just you
know a lot of i mean william james
points this out a lot of what we're
doing is a matter of temperament um i
like mariluponte
i like other people better and there's
so many other people
you know
that uh i i focus on them i you know i i
went to the maryland ponte circle and
and actually wrote some pieces on merlot
ponte back and i'm not quite sure what's
what's going on um
it says please wait while we try
reconnecting that does not sound
particularly
good there we go we must be reconnected
i mean you might as well ask why isn't
uh boethius in your top ten or you know
anything like that so it's not always
like there's a big critique of that
person it's just you know they're
they're not that that big in my
my own thing
moises says i'm taking a class on
nietzsche's beyond and beyond good and
evil and we're using nietzsche's like
our connection again is
unstable i am not sure what's going on
with the interwebs here but i'm i'm sure
you know
bear with me on it
quite sure what what's happening
sometimes there's construction here in
the downtown or winds can screw things
up
so anyway um
uh yeah
when it comes to any any given secondary
literature odds are that anybody that
you ask unless they're just specializing
in that secondary literature
have not actually
read it um
far so far some i skipped over this one
what are your thoughts on embodied
cognition
that's you know so broad um i think that
uh embodiment is part of cognition and
that's you know there's many ways to
approach that so there's not much more
to say about that
toxicolarus what do you think of the
transcendental argument for god if
you've heard of it that is i may have
like read about it somewhere under a
different name but i have no idea what
is actually meant by the transcendental
argument for god
that could mean just about anything so
if you could uh maybe index where you're
finding it
that might be helpful
uh thunderbirds do you have any thoughts
on david bentley heart yeah interesting
guy
um unlike most of the eastern orthodox
he actually is willing to read and uh
think about saint anselm without a
knee-jerk response against him which is
cool as well so um but i'm not i'm not
particularly into heart
uh dylan vera are you interested in the
work of judith butler i don't think i've
heard you mention her before
yeah i mean i've read butler i sometimes
teach her in classes again you know just
because
uh you haven't heard me mention her
doesn't mean that i don't have any
particular interest you know the the
youtube channel is sort of like this
tiny little narrow thing this window
where people look in
and you know what what we actually do
all of us academics and people living
lives
is much broader so
um i mean butler became became a thing
way back when i was in grad school uh
zeno what do you think of ralph waldo
emerson i found what you said about
taking a break from philosophers i tend
to do things chronologically
emerson is okay um
you know he's uh he fits into the
american
tradition you know classical american
philosophy on the transcendentalist end
um
there's a good bit more like just
spinning things out and saying things
then there is like
you know carefully constructed argument
that i think he he like many of the
transcendentalists plays rather fast and
loose with the sources that he's using
but he's an interesting guy um there's
there's people out there who do you know
good work with him
interestingly there's um
there's a guy down in
orlando
uh who goes by the the moniker stoic dan
who likes to you know draw comparisons
between the transcendentalists and the
stoics
that's interesting stuff you know
yeah
all right mark smith
any biographies you find particularly
interesting as in a life you think is
worth remembering
and maybe even studying
so i don't read a lot of
biographies um i will say that
you know if if you're
interested in ancient philosophy
um one of the people who's well worth
reading that a lot of people think is
just a biographer is plutarch he's got
all this great you know middle platonist
stuff on uh it's called the moralia on
all sorts of things but then he's also
got these lives and he says listen i'm
not trying to provide a history of the
person i'm trying to provide you with an
understanding of
their morals and
their decision-making processes and
stuff like that so that that's kind of
cool i mean
intellectual biographies um you know the
only one i've read
really for quite a while other than like
you know i have read uh uh some of uh
salome yeah lou andre salome's stuff on
rilka and nietzsche
um would be oliver blanchett's massive
intellectual biography of maurice
blondell maurice blondella philosophical
life which is quite good
um
[Music]
but i don't i don't usually have too
much time to be reading
uh biographies you know
i mean most of what i end up doing is
reading stuff
that's you could say biographical
for some of those lectures that i give
in the philosophers in the midst of
history or or i read stuff that has to
do with the authors that i'm covering in
the worlds of speculative fiction
uh see amano what is the best way to
fully if it is even possible understand
hegel where to start start by getting
rid of any worries about best way and
start by actually reading hegel
and then you're gonna be dismayed
because it's difficult and you're not
sure what the hell you're doing and then
just keep at it you know don't worry
about best ways that's that's a good bit
of advice because there is no best way
first of all generally and this goes not
just for hegel but for any philosopher
there's no best way to study plato
there's no best way to study
plutarch there's no best way to study
judith butler right there are
good there are you know good and and bad
ways you could say like um starting by
just reading
tendentious secondary works or blog
posts probably not the way to go
starting by just watching videos
probably not the way to go you know you
gotta you gotta read the actual author
but
there is no one single
one size fits all best for everybody
thing because we you know philosophy is
complicated it's sort of like saying
what's the best way to
learn the history of music
there isn't one best way you know you
have to find what works for you
and then
dig into that and then look around and
see what's working for other people
and appropriate what you think from them
could be good and avoid gurus who like
have the single way to do things because
they're they're usually
um peddling something or crazy or you
know they don't know what they're
talking about
i will say this um i wouldn't start with
the phenomenology of spirit although a
lot of people really
are enamored of that if you are going to
do the phenomenology spirit read the
whole the whole book right don't just
read you know the parts that seem sexy
or that people talk about but i i
usually tell people start with the
lectures on the history of philosophy
why because you can see what hegel is
saying about people who presumably you
already know something about like say
plato or you know the stoics or
descartes right and then read his
lectures on the philosophy of history
which is already
kind of kind of tricky but at least he's
naming names in there and then after
that you can go to the phenomenology or
go to the logic or the philosophy of
right or whatever else it is that you
want to do right
all right
uh
chica says professor please start taking
classes on everything related to
literature and english
every writer's in their work maybe you
mean like offering classes but i mean
this is one of those things where time
is a constraint and um
you know why should i do something that
somebody else can do better like for
example i recently
um in my social media and in my
community tab on youtube
highlighted somebody else's logic
channel right a professor uh from from
england and uh she's very good um why
should i replicate the work that she's
doing same thing with literature you
know um there are some works of
literature that i can do well but i
think there's people who are far more
specialized than i am who might be
better at that and you know we only have
24 hours a day
so i'm you know i'm i'm glad i'm able to
get done when i'm able to get done
so
all right you're you're average it just
skipped a little bit your average
frenchman was it uh
french canadian immigrant i'm reading
bergson and anselm on truth they
convinced me that there's an existential
truth that can't be scientific it's
almost contra scientific any authors
that expand on that idea
um
i mean
i would i would avoid the
you know can't be scientific stuff
because that's kind of
you know
that that's sort of a red hearing that's
not part going to help you you're not
getting that out of anselm uh because he
doesn't say anything remotely like that
um you might be getting that out of
bergstone there are you know countless
authors who are discussing the nature of
truth
it's discussed in plato and aristotle
aristotle actually distinguishes between
practical truth and theoretical truth
you know the stoics are discussing it
sextus empiricus has all sorts of cool
discussions of it that's just in ancient
times then you have you know like
augustine
and uh you know boethius and all these
other thinkers that are approaching the
question of truth and then it goes all
the way up to
you know the present day where we have
deflationists and we have you know
heidegger and truth is all atheia so
there's like a huge range of people who
are
uh discussing the nature of truth and
the one thing that you can say is that
there is no one single theory of truth
that encompasses everything that we mean
by by truth
um so you know there's there's uh lots
and lots of people that you can
you can quite easily find
i've long wanted to have the time to
actually write a book about
conceptions of truth but we'll see if i
ever get around to that
um
max any particular parts you favor about
machiavelli or nietzsche's writings
i mean
if you mean are there concepts that i
take from their writings
sure i mean machiavelli
says that the rich are always is in the
prince are always going to be pricks who
are trying to
uh dominate the weak and so and the poor
or the many and so it's the job of the
prince to actually whip the the rich
into line and make sure that they don't
engage in that sort of thing and i think
he's right about that
and you know
he's uh he's got some very interesting
observations on a number of other topics
people often misjudge machiavelli
because they only read the prince and
they only read it with this blinder on
that you know the ends justify the means
raw power better to be feared than loved
and they kind of lose sight of what it
is that his his project is you know
um
nietzsche's got all sorts of cool stuff
in in his works you know i think that
there is something like a will to power
it's not all that the will does and i
think he got that wrong
but um i think that that you know that
is part of it and he problematizes the
unity of the virtues in a very
interesting way
i think that his uh diagnosis of
resentment is is very helpful
um there's many people who are basically
afflicted with resentment including some
people who would call themselves
nietzscheans um you know there's there's
i mean some of the the history that he
provides us with is very speculative and
you're like yeah come on i don't know
about you know this history of uh the
development of greek uh um
modes of poetry leading up to tragedy
and then you know it was euripides and
and socrates that that screwed
everything up you know there's some
things where you're like come on
nietzsche
um but he's got you know there's a lot
of things to recommend his his work he's
very attuned to
uh the the use of metaphor i think that
it is an important question that we have
to ask what is this philosopher really
after the conception evaluation
is kind of a cool idea as well
yes hi hi professor who's your favorite
philosopher i don't have a favorite
philosopher anymore that i have a
favorite band
i have like lots of people who i like
and who fit into kind of a framework but
you know
if you if you ask me like come up with a
rank ordering i would be i would have a
very hard time doing that whether it's
for
philosophy or for music or literature or
anything like that you know i have i
have a lot of people who who i like
um
let's see
valuska do you have any recommendations
on secondary lit on hegel that follows a
metaphysical reading like visors it
doesn't have to be in english no i don't
really have recommendations on secondary
lit i mean i spend very little time with
secondary literature because i'm mostly
oriented towards teaching and producing
videos on and
giving you know
writing and stuff on primary literature
and since i don't work just on one
person you know i work on a whole bunch
of people
that's that's rather difficult to do so
wakar
asks this question that somebody always
asks every single time would you make
videos on arab muslim philosophy no
because i'm not really qualified to do
that you want to find somebody who's
like me who can actually
read arabic and who has the same sort of
like attentiveness that i have to hegel
on my part they have to you know even
rushed or
whoever else you're going to bring up
i'm not the person to do that
anymore that i'm the person to do uh
works in indian philosophy i don't read
sanskrit you know
um
that's the sort of thing where we have a
division of labor right
xenovalea thoughts on anti-natalism i
don't really take it that seriously
it seems to become quite popular as a
movement
you know in the internet sphere i mean
there were some philosophers who were
anti-natalist
in the past but it's you know it's
become kind of a sexy topic right but
i'm not really that
that interested in it myself um
[Music]
all right uh made of clay how do you
remember everything you talk about i
don't
so that's that's kind of a uh
non-starter right there i don't remember
everything that i talk about i i trace
over a lot of the same ground you know
but i mean people will write me on a
video that's 10 years old and they'll be
like at you know 59.30
you said xyz what did you mean by that
i'll be like how the hell would i know i
mean that's like 2 000 videos ago
10 years ago i don't even remember
everything that i said to my wife
yesterday in our conversation so so i
don't i don't remember everything that i
i talk about um so let me read the rest
of this besides constantly studying or
rereading what helps you remember
everything you know
i really want to feel like i know but i
find it hard to remember so there's
there's a couple things to say first of
all i'm not rereading and studying all
the time i live a life as well i take
baths in which i read fiction stuff in
the bath or i you know check twitter on
my phone i you know make meals and eat
them my wife and i will sit down and
watch a show together i'll go to the
coffee house and hopefully get some work
done you know answering emails and stuff
like that i teach classes so you know
the the majority of my time
is not actually spent um studying and
rereading i would say you know on a good
day i get to do like you know four or
five hours of that now i did have the
benefit of
going to graduate school and also i
would say undergrad kind of fit in this
as well when i had a lot more time on my
hands and i could just you know read and
think about stuff
and the graduate school that i went to
even though it's considered low tier i
probably got a better education there
than i would have gotten going to an ivy
because we had very very rigorous
uh preliminary examinations that you had
to study for which they've long since
gotten rid of because so many people you
know did poorly on them
and it also had a major research library
and and so you know you could you could
study stuff in depth and doing that was
kind of helpful sort of like you know
musicians who practice as my my good
friend scott truly did when he was in
his 20s eight hours a day
you you build up a kind of um
you know memory by doing that
but i i will say this you know how like
people in in talking about truth and
lies will say you're better off telling
the truth because then you don't have to
remember any lies
it's kind of like that with the history
of philosophy
if you just read the people and you
teach them as they are without coming at
it with some sort of agenda or some big
schema like you know these are these
people who fit here and these are these
people who fit here but you do it just
you know because you like uh teaching
aristotle or mary wallstonecraft or
whoever
you're you're basically saying the truth
is best you know about those people and
then you don't have to
you don't have to remember
any other things you can just like go to
the text and be like well what's
happening here ah you know same as it
was last time that i read it you know so
i think that's helpful as well
uh paul litter are ryan holiday's books
a good resource for people new to
stoicism do you have any suggestions for
people new to stoicism
his texts are mediocre
i would say and sometimes misleading
sometimes the translations are actually
off uh with things you can find in in
his works
my wife and i started doing the daily
stoic which i'd gotten as a sort of
party favor back in stoich on
2016 and we had to quit after a while
because the you know the quotes were
fine
there's daily quotes in there but then
his his discussion of it was so often
just not very good and sometimes
actually wrong
so i don't recommend ryan holiday no um
and you know can he be sort of a gateway
i mean it's sort of like jordan peterson
people are always like oh jordan
peterson's so great and you're like the
guy sucks he actually doesn't know what
the hell he's talking about then they're
like but he turned me on to nietzsche
and then you're like well [ __ ] read
nietzsche don't bother with this fool
you know um
and i'm not going to say that ryan
holiday is is that but
he's not a
great interpreter of the stoic he's more
of a guy who's great at marketing um and
you know
happened to jump on to a bandwagon as it
was going on there's so much better
stuff that you could read even if you
just want to read like popular stuff
read john sellers or read massimo
pigliucci or read donald robertson or
some of these people who actually know
the stoic literature really really well
that they're introducing you to and
they're not going to mess it up with all
this you know
self-helpy you know let's let's all get
ahead kind of stuff
um
are there any suggestions for people new
to stoicism i wrote a whole medium piece
reading suggestions for for stoicism
that i every once in a while will post
in social media
and i give you like you know i think you
should start out with the actual texts
don't don't dick around with secondary
literature all of you are smart enough
to actually read some cicero some
epictetus um some seneca some you know
marcus aurelius all of you are smart
enough to do that don't shortchange
yourself and think that you have to um
you know read this watered-down kind of
stuff right go directly to the sources
and i give you a structure for that i
say you know start with these three then
go to these three and then do this then
do that so i mean all you got to do is
google sadler stoicism reading
recommendations and you know you'll find
that
all right cola moose would you ever do
videos on coleridge or man to be ram
i haven't read men to be ran since
graduate school he's a pretty obscure
guy
so i mean there's probably hundreds of
people i would do before getting to him
coleridge um
okay i could see doing some stuff on on
his work because he did influence the
transcendentalists as a matter of fact
a lot of their con they're getting
secondhand through coleridge so he he'd
be worth doing but i mean most of the
time
i'm shooting videos on people who i'm
teaching in my classes and i i haven't
um taught coleridge boy since i was
teaching in the prison so a long time
ago
toxic collaris orthodox christian
transcendental argument presented by
jade dyer for god is the argument that
god is the necessary precondition for
the knowledge of metaphysics
epistemology and ethics
doesn't sound like much of an argument
to me and i i don't i you know i quit
following jay dyer because of the crazy
crap that he was uh posting on on
twitter so i can't imagine that there's
there's too much there
it does sound like stuff that other
people were proposing
um
back in the day but boy that's a big
claim for knowledge of metaphysics
epistemology and ethics um yeah i don't
know
all right mike ray are you familiar with
bianchol han and his critique of
neoliberalism i am not specifically as a
burnout society where everyone has to be
an entrepreneur someone who has to
constantly improve themselves no but
that sounds kind of interesting might be
worth checking out sometime down the
line i don't know
impulsive is heidegger's nietzsche worth
reading in your opinion uh more broadly
all of heidegger's lectures are worth
reading in my opinion you'll often find
yourself if you know the primary
thinker that he's engaging with you will
find yourself saying oh
that's kind of insightful and then
you'll also find yourself saying no i
think he went off the track here but
this is typical heidegger but
heidegger going wrong is
still worth reading and the nietzsche
lectures are very in-depth um and they
are they are very well worth reading
another secondary lit thing that i would
say is also worth reading is deluse's
nietzsche book you know
as a matter of fact when we
when we had our nietzsche seminar in
graduate school those were the only two
secondary lit things that we we had all
the rest was reading nietzsche i got to
present the duluth because i was like
really into toulouse's history of
philosophy stuff at the time and into
nietzsche um
so yeah i would i would read the
nietzsche lectures they're they're worth
getting i think they're pretty cheap too
uh and all their voices opinions on
second part of being in time is it worth
the read
yeah if you can if you can understand it
if you've got the stamina to get through
it it's definitely worth the read
um why why would you only read half a
book
you know
if you sort of like you know start well
people do this right when they teach
they're like i'm going to teach
descartes meditations and then they only
teach meditation one and two and you're
like
what what the hell's that about i mean
you're you're only gonna get us up to
the piece of wax and being a thinking
thing you're gonna skip all the other
cool stuff that's happening there you
know
uh let's see
rt whitby did nietzsche consider anyone
who lived before during a lifetime and
ubermensch or the person who he believed
was the closest to being an ubermensch
well we don't know because he doesn't
say
so and so was an ubermensch and he
figures the ubermentor the superperson
as um something
yet to come right so
who knows you know there's lots of
people who make arguments i will say
this sort of facetiously there's a lot
of uh people who read nietzsche for the
first time and they're like
i'm gonna be an uber mention
and you know nietzsche's response to
that would be nobody no you're not
so yeah
ephron is phenomenology important yes i
mean it's one of the big um
branches you could say of continental
philosophy in the 1930s thomas started
recognizing quite explicitly that the
phenomenologists and thomas were doing
interesting things which gave rise to a
lot of cool crossovers in the west and
also to the lublin school in poland
which is by the way where carol voltea
who later becomes john paul ii came from
yeah phenomenology is important um do
you have to study every single figure in
phenomenology i don't think that you
even could i mean hustle himself left
behind
tens of thousands of shorthand pages in
the whisser archives that people go and
check out so yeah
muzzle paint uh i brought my british
steel album to the bus stop to show it
off in late spring 1980 i've seen
priests in europe asia and usa always
confusing my anabaptist congregation
with my love of metal so he's responding
to here's you know my
british steel
shirt which by the way there's a really
cool picture of me with one of my kids
when when she was really small and i'm
like holding her and you know it looks
like the hand on the shirt is actually
holding her
we've seen priest four times my wife and
i in the last uh 10 years all here in
the states uh two of them in here here
in milwaukee and we started joking
around
that because they always have like a
cool um
opening band you know um like we saw
uriah heap with them and saxon and black
star rider and thin lizzy
and steel panther
um on on various tours and so we were
joking around that you know
getting to see another new band is sort
of like the consolation prize to going
to a priest concert
i i will say though they they are when
you know in the recent years boy they
really put on a hell of a show so
all right uh ridicule do you consider
democracy as a value in itself i feel
like i know intuitively but what exactly
do philosophers mean when they talk
about values in that way
i don't know that democracy
by itself is you know
inherently a good thing that we have to
strive for it really depends on what you
mean
by democracy and you know somebody who i
got um you know a lot of when i was in
grad school was john dewey because you
know
southern illinois university
uh pluralistic department analytics
continental and classical american and
they had the center for dewey studies
there as well
and so it was dewey dewey dewey all the
time in democracy democracy democracy
all the time and you'd be like what do
you mean by democracy and they give you
like well it's this and this and this
and this and you'd be like can you
center in on one of them so we could
just talk about that aspect are you
talking about voting are you talking
about everybody gets to like express
themselves are you talking about the
liberation what what does democracy
actually translate into and a lot of
times people that just have kind of a
warm fuzzy you know
excuse me
democracy is this this good thing
it all depends on what you mean by it i
think and so
you know there's certain aspects that
you know you think about plato and his
criticism of democracy was plato
criticizing all democracy and all
aspects
no not necessarily but he was seeing
some of the failures in athenian
democracy right so
yeah
philosophers i think a lot of them have
a warm fuzzy association with democracy
but
um i don't know that that goes beyond
that sort of emotional attachment
uh showab uh i'm from pakistan want to
read philosophy for personal interest
don't know enough language to read and
to understand the philosophical
literature i'll be thankful for your
advice well you know just start where
you are and you got your lifetime ahead
of you um you can keep on reading and
reading and reading and you acquire the
capacities to to do that i think right i
mean the good news is because you have
access to the internet
almost everything up until you know the
1950s is available for you online
free i mean some of it isn't translated
but
there's so many there's so many
philosophers that you can you can find
uh easily online
um
alfonso uh in what ways does the lack of
providence damage stoic ethics is it
possible to replace logos with science
even if reason could fall into
instrumental reason
so um i don't think the lack of
providence damages stoic ethics at all i
think that a lot of it is independent of
believing in a providential ordering of
things
and this is where like you know
traditional stoics and modern stoics
different and traditional stoics are
um sort of hyper orthodox and and uh in
my interactions with them not
particularly enjoyable people um and you
know they they tend to say oh well if
you get rid of providence everything
else falls apart and
you know it's sort of like the the
christian arguments oh if god doesn't
exist then morality doesn't exist and
you're like well you just showed me that
you are a shitty person who can't be
relied upon to do the right thing and
you know even in ancient stoicism you
have marcus irelia saying
hell providence or atoms
who knows what it is i can still do the
right thing so even in in
you know classical stoicism as opposed
to modern
traditional stoicism you don't
necessarily need providence
is it possible to replace logos with
science
why would you want to
um i mean you want to turn science into
this this big thing that we have you
know sort of sweeping assumptions about
um
there's a thing called scientism which
is you know
a problematic aspect that you see the
you know i effin love science crowd
getting into and richard dawkins
embarrassing himself with every once in
a while or neil degrasse tyson is a good
example of that as well why why the hell
would we want that you know why not um
aim at just being rational and say that
we have to re-understand what logos
rationality
means i mean that's that seems perfectly
in consonance with classical stoicism to
me
um
xenovalea i claudius by robert graves is
a book i've been reading meaning to read
do you like historical fiction are there
any books you recommend
i don't read historical fiction um i
would guess in part because i you know i
don't have the time to read everything
i'd like to read anyway and i've got
other genres that i'm more into
like um you know
fantasy and sci-fi and
horror and alternate histories and stuff
like that
so
yeah i just i'm not that into those
things you know and also good straight
out literature like graham green i don't
get enough time to do that kind of
reading
um so
finding another genre probably not in
the cards for me right
john ortiz how does one become a
logician well so you gotta like go to
this door in the city and you knock on
it three times and you say logos logos
logos and then they open it up and they
ask you for the password again i mean
there isn't any like way you become a
logician
you uh study logic and then you
mess around with it how do you become a
musician how do you become a
you know an iron worker you
work in a certain field and you kind of
learn as you go
sv can you tell us some contemporary
philosophers you like well everyone
knows i'm a big fan of aleister mcintyre
who i've i've actually met
julia annas i'm a big fan of her and her
work as well
margaret graver
great translator and and she's got an
awesome book on stoicism and the
emotions
um
you know if you're if you're talking
about people that are doing more like on
their own kind of work uh not not you
know
more historically oriented
i'd have to think about that you know um
i'm not i'm not somebody who's like
looking for the sort of latest things
going on
and i'm very appreciative of those who
are
good at incorporating the insights of
other
people from from the past
uh efron who who is superior
philosophically husserl or heidegger
totally wrong-headed question why why
who
superior what the hell does that mean
you know
you'd have to clarify in what respect
you want somebody to be superior and i
think you should
think about like why you want why why
are you worried about that i mean spend
some time reading them and you can come
to your own judgment
xenoblade do you like reading philosophy
chronologically or do you pick out one
by random and researched by that neither
i mean my my formative days were over
uh half my lifetime ago and i
did things kind of chronologically and
kind of
uh
you know haphazardly
and
um
you know i've been reading and
researching and and engaging in
philosophy for more than half my life
now actually
about 30 of my 50 years in in a you know
explicit uh structured way
so
there isn't there isn't any original way
to go about it for me i've been doing
this for so long
um i mean you could say when you're when
you're presenting something do you want
to present it chronologically or or you
know topic wise or something like that
that could make make more sense
um
made of clay i think the biggest problem
when reading hegel is he refers to his
terms once when he begins to talk about
them then just calls his concepts as it
for the next 10 paragraphs
yeah that's more in the phenomenology
than in other works but that is uh uh
difficulty you have to do a lot of work
figuring out some of the time
what is hegel actually referring to
when he's he's he's uh saying and and
then it does or it breaks up into three
moments or stuff like that right
uh yeah admittedly that that could be a
problem with with hegel um it could be a
problem with all sorts of people
all right uh let's see what else we got
here
it just uh skipped through a whole bunch
of people's stuff
um
uh camogello um
what comparative analysis would you give
between philosophy and theology i
wouldn't give a comparative analysis
uh those are those terms are too too
broad uh you could talk about
so-and-so's philosophy and so-and-so's
theology or you could talk about this
movement in philosophy and this movement
in theology but there's no like
side-by-side comparison of philosophy
and theology that is not already like
assuming lots and lots and lots of stuff
um
roger i love your lecture on rilka
i've got a number of lectures on america
but i'm glad that you like one of them
michael where can someone get started
with philosophy of science
um i mean you could you could actually
like this is the kind of thing where you
could go to the internet and go to like
the internet encyclopedia philosophy or
stanford encyclopedia philosophy and
then you know read their entries and
then look at the bibliography and then
maybe start reading some of the primary
texts in the bibliography that might be
a good thing um
john ortiz advice for starting or
thinking about a career what kind of
career right i mean i don't think that
there is a one-size-fit-all thing
about careers other than probably
expect that it's not going to last your
whole lifetime right
rt whitby what do you think about
voltaire
i think voltaire was kind of a prick um
he's an interesting guy i i you know i
actually years and years back i read
through all of his uh
novels
um
i went on sort of a voltaire kick and i
was like yeah some of these are pretty
good some of these
maybe not quite so much
um
you know he's he's a sort of a second
rate philosopher but that's great
because second rate is still second rate
you know
better than than most of us um
worth worth reading
it won't take you long to figure out
voltaire's basic shtick you know
um
know nothing says hey after many people
have told me philosophy is dead and i'm
wasting my time with philosophy i
eventually convinced myself it was true
i'm majoring in a chemistry how do i
regain my passion don't worry about
regaining a passion passions are
pretty
mercurial right
i mean ask yourself this
why the hell would you believe people
telling you some silly thing about an
entire field
you know where where do they derive
their knowledge from that philosophy is
dead how do you know they're not full of
crap
why did you buy into them i mean ask
yourself that did you just give in to
peer pressure or the desire to be liked
or you know the wish to have
conversations with people i mean there
there are literally
hundreds of thousands of people that you
could easily connect with in the world
for whom philosophy clearly isn't dead
who are doing interesting work in
philosophy
why not connect up with one of them you
know why not find a local philosophy
club why not read for yourself and then
you could also say
this idea that philosophy is dead is
that a new idea or that have people been
you know preaching that sort of thing in
superficial ways for
you know roughly the last
150 years you know
which is quite true so
yeah i mean
why why would you want to uh buy into
that
david says who did you do your thesis on
to get your master's hussarl and
dissociur
um
[Music]
and i ended up replicating some of what
derrida is doing in speech and phenomena
which i hadn't read at that time
uh ariel what are some of your favorite
movies have you seen in broogs yeah i
saw i saw um
in bruggs uh a while back with with my
wife uh it's not bad um
some of my favorite movies
uh the duelist um which is a 1970s
ridley scott movie uh with i want to say
david
david or peter carradine and harvey
keitel it's probably my favorite movie
um i also really liked the three
musketeers and the four musketeers when
i was a kid i wanted to be a sword
fighter when i was a kid
there wasn't a lot of call for that uh
but man did i want to be a uh a duelist
um
[Music]
you know there's lots of movies that are
that are quite good um i mean things
don't come to mind
usually what would be like top of mind
would be like holy [ __ ] that was an
awesome movie that i saw recently but
i've actually been watching a lot more
tv shows than movies so i haven't had
that experience
recently
yeah
back moon
how would you reform philosophy
education what changes to the curriculum
would you make and what primary texts
would you emphasize
what philosophy curriculum it's being
taught differently all over the place i
i think you're assuming that we would
somehow
standardize it i mean in in other
countries like if you have like a high
school
philosophy there could be like a
standard curriculum right
but that sure isn't the case here in the
united states where we don't have
philosophy in most high schools and when
you get to college there isn't a
standard curriculum
even in the same
[Music]
department intro to philosophy might be
taught very very different ways you know
when i taught at marquette
there was a foundations of philosophy
class
and the four requirements for it was you
had to have
some plato or aristotle you had to have
a philosopher from
the
catholic intellectual tradition because
marquette's you know catholic school you
had to have a
feminist or non-western philosopher
and and you had to have one contemporary
philosopher and i tried to get you know
clarification does simone bouvoir count
as contemporary yeah i guess so you know
does hana rent count as contemporary
yeah i guess so you know they they
couldn't really say it so i
it's kind of a non-starter how would we
reform philosophy education
you know things are too heterogenous to
to really do that
all right um
no nothing common how many languages do
you know depends on what you mean by no
i mean i can
read but it's slow in in greek and latin
and um
you know every author that if you're
doing a new author you often have to
like sort of tool up on their vocabulary
and it takes a while to get used to it i
can read german if i need to
you know and i'm in country for a while
i can haltingly speak german the last
time i did that was when i was in
switzerland in sas faye at european
graduate school and it took me about a
week before i was able to like you know
draw upon my capacities and
have any sort of uh
more than just a few sentences
conversation but i can read german you
know
and um french you know it's been a long
time since i spoke in french my mother
you know her first language was french
and same with all of her
her family and i used to be quite good
with it but being partly deaf hurts your
comprehension considerably
because there's all these things that
are not really silent letters but are
kind of silent
um but i can read french you know uh
very easily and i i translate from latin
and german and french and greek
um so it all depends on what you mean by
no right that's kind of sort of a
pragmatic term
uh david in 20 it's 2022 who do you
recommend for nowadays in the year that
we're in now for a philosopher to read i
mean whoever you want to
what what's
what's unique about 2022
i often say let's start with plato you
know
he's a good person i think to begin with
um
abhishek any book suggestion for
politics where different forms of
government is discussed again we could
start with plato right uh republic book
eight has five different forms of
government being discussed i mean you
could also look at aristotle's politics
six forms of government maybe seven if
dunastea is another one that that can be
uh discussed and then it just goes on
from there cilia your video on anselm
helped me a lot from my class thank you
i'm glad it helped i don't know which
video you're referencing because i think
at this point in time i've probably got
40 or so videos on anselm so
all right absurdo what's going on with
all the pronoun stuff i'm in portugal
and u.s social media has become alien to
me last four to five years teachers
crying on tick-tock when kids forget the
correct pronoun
um is academia the same worse are they
still same i've been a leftist my whole
life but this is driving me crazy it's
driving you crazy because you're letting
it drive you crazy i mean it's not
really that big of a deal there's so
many other things
and uh if you choose to like focus on
that uh you know
when there's so many other things you
could be focusing on
i guess you want to ask yourself why why
you're doing that you know
maybe follow some people that aren't
obsessed with pronouns
this seems this seems like a very simple
thing to to resolve um i mean i'm i'm
cool with calling people by the pronouns
that they they want
i teach at a school where
this is very common
and you know it's expected that you'll
probably screw up every once in a while
and misgender somebody actually one of
my my daughters you know jokingly told
me i misgendered her because she's going
by they them and i was like well you
didn't tell me you switched because you
were going by she they
and um you know it's it's it's not that
big of a deal people are not
getting in each other's faces most of
the time it's like you're misgendering
me it's more like
yeah you know i kind of prefer that you
do this and then other people get all
worked up about it and the people who
get all worked up about it
in english we use they a lot
even the people like jordan peterson who
are like oh i'm against pronouns and
this bill is blah blah blah blah blah he
was using they
to describe people
in that very rant that he was doing it's
a very common thing so
um
i wouldn't let it stress you out too
much i mean that's a choice on your part
there's so many other topics i mean you
could talk about unionization you're big
on the left cool amazon just got one of
its places unionized focus on that
instead right
uh
fresh jordan is being in time a must
read um i mean it's a
should read
it'd be good for you to read it i think
is it a must read um i mean ask yourself
this was was anybody who was born in the
1800s missing something because they
hadn't read being in time
you know
um
are there people who
you know did philosophy in the 20th
century and didn't read being in time
who then you know were handicapped by
the fact that they didn't read being in
time you know must read is is a that's a
pretty high bar right i guess you could
say must for for what
um
roughly
says
how wrong do you think it is that i find
nietzsche's thus spoke zarathustra more
spiritually fulfilling than augustine's
confessions i even get more out of camus
the fall reading the falls and inverted
confessions i don't see a problem with
that i mean
again i'm a pluralist right
where where i think there's a problem
are the people who are like you know
augustine is presupposing the existence
of our god and you know they get all
worked up about that sort of crap and
and you know they don't actually like
read the confessions and see where it's
going and what he has to say um
i mean i think that
um
i mean
if i had to pick a camusian work
that i would focus on the most it
probably wouldn't be the fall it
probably would be the plague
or weirdly enough letters to a german
friend
but they're all of great you know moral
and um human depth you could say right
and we don't always you know we don't
have to feel under pressure to always
like
other people like this work so therefore
i have to like this work or i'm missing
out on something
the world of literature is so
broad
and there's so many
great things that we could read in it
that we're we're super fortunate in in
the time that we live in you know it's
not like we're ancient greeks and
basically we got homer and hessian and a
few other things you know are you know
some some lyric poetry and that's it you
know we've got this incredibly rich
banquet in front of us and so if you get
more out of the spoke zarathustra and
camus the fall then augustine's
confessions that's that's fine then you
know spend more time with them that
might change too as you get older um or
your perspective changes over time i
mean i think about texts that i thought
well so somebody's got a question about
aristotle uh down the line i you know
when i first read aristotle i was like
this is really dry boring stuff i i
don't see why anyone would want to read
it it's either like totally common sense
or it's uh
basically nonsense
then i learned to
pay attention to what i was seeing in
aristotle's
ethical and political works and
things opened up for me same thing for
you know reading marcus aurelius you
know i
i read marcus aurelius when i was in
college i thought it's a cool thing i'm
not in all this justice prudence stuff
but you know
i like the toughness and i missed a
whole bunch of things and so you know
that's okay that we don't have we don't
all have to do the same thing you know
um
michael jimenez what is the most
overlooked part of aristotle's
metaphysics
i don't know i mean how would we how
would we answer that sort of question
um
i i it's not like i do a survey of
people studying aristotle's metaphysics
and then um
you know look for whatever is the the
least treated i i don't know how he
would answer that
um
cinder what do you think of r g
collingwood's idea of metaphysics of the
study of absolute presuppositions does
this lead to relativism i don't think it
leads to relativism
i think that usually when we say oh you
know metaphysics is fundamentally about
this
you know however talented we are in
collingwood as a talented thinker and
writer we're probably leaving some stuff
out you know
david says i was wondering if you had a
recommendation on a polisher how
thoth it to teach slave women and all
classes of people i don't even know what
that means that's kind of some word
salad there so i don't know
what you have in mind ridicule i heard
sad uh guru the indian mystic tell
people to drop their philosophies
because they're just a bunch of people
obsessed with words and not reality
frustrates me when people worship these
girls okay so this this is a good thing
to to talk about um and this kind of
goes back to the question
uh that absurdo had about the pronoun
stuff
so
the world is full of jackasses
and
you know fakes and
scam artists and and guru types right
[Music]
and
you know there's going to be people
worked up about all sorts of crazy crap
at any given time and giving bad advice
that doesn't necessarily have to affect
us and i and i'm i'm sympathetic to this
that pisses me off you know seeing that
that sort of thing going on because i i
you know i also don't like seeing
uh people
um being held up as oh this is so smart
and great and we have to follow these
people when you're like this is
this is garbage you know what's wrong
with you
but again we don't have to allow it to
get to us that that is a choice on our
part and we probably are better off if
we do wean ourselves away from that
because there isn't a hell of a lot we
can do right other than just keep on
doing the good work that we're doing
and letting people be attracted to that
[Music]
there will probably always be
more people attracted to these guru
types than their will to people who you
know have something real to offer
it was that way back in in ancient times
it's going to be that way probably
throughout human uh
future
so
yeah and you can you know drop your
philosophies when somebody says that you
have to say well what do they mean by
philosophy you know and are they
peddling a philosophy as well right so
all right um
is that l hegelians all view history as
a duality between rest justice history
which is becoming and written history
which has
happened how do you describe this
objective problem oh all hug aliens
believe that that's interesting i don't
know that that's the case
so i don't know that all hegelians
believe any one single thing other than
that maybe hegel is important
so that's kind of a non-starter
uh joe mama saw you mentioned on twitter
recently a distaste for rorty is it his
speedy history of philosophy that
bothers you or you're not really a fan
of neopragmatism at large
or about abandoning experience i think
that rorty was kind of a second-rate
philosopher
he was a big deal when i was in graduate
school and people were reading him and
talking about him and a lot of what he
he has to say is sort of from like a an
elite you know privileged position
uh east coaster saying oh you knew
philosophy the way that we've been doing
it is
hopeless prospect and you know we don't
have to pay attention to these things
anymore and i think that his readings of
a lot of people are just not very good
you know not very attentive
that said he has some good readings of
some people
but you know
i i think he he substitutes assertion
for
actual argument or justification a lot
and he does so in the same way that like
when mcintyre talks about the bloomsbury
group in uh the you know beginning of
the 20th century
um and after virtue it's the same sort
of thing it's just done from a
neopragmatist thing and
if rorty is a is what neopragmatism is
then neopragmatism isn't very
interesting um
fortunately there's a lot of other
people out there who are
doing better work i would say than rorty
um and they're drawing on if you want to
be a neopragmatist you better be drawing
on uh purse and james and dewey and and
you know probably royce is also
important in there as well and you
better be you know showing a pragmatic
attitude towards things so
all right um
where uh ks what do you think the future
of the academic philosophy professor
career is will it keep shrinking
um
now if you mean tenure track
uh academic philosophy yeah that's gonna
keep shrinking
at least here in the united states i
can't speak for
canada or australia or
japan
or you know france or any of those
places those those are other
systems
but yeah tenure track jobs are going to
continue to shrink there's plenty of
work if you want to be an adjunct
and sometimes adjuncting can be okay
like you know me being an adjunct at
milwaukee institute of art design is
pretty good
i don't teach anymore for milwaukee area
technical college i'm going to stop
teaching for carthage college
as an adjunct pretty soon
and you know
i also have my own business so i'm not
just dependent on on going from college
to college so there will be work um it's
i think you have in mind like tenure
track professor
um that's gonna keep shrinking
and um
it's gonna be dominated by those who go
to elite schools and are part of an
elite
and who use their connections to
get ahead and pretend that they're part
of a meritocracy when really they just
happen to have won the lottery right
but that doesn't keep you necessarily
from doing philosophy all right there's
going to be all sorts of cool stuff
going on there already is cool stuff
going on
zeno did you did you have any other
interests outside of philosophy did you
have a degree before philosophy
well my undergraduate degree was in
philosophy and mathematics
and i actually
wavered
in the year that i was just working
before i went to graduate school should
i go to graduate school for philosophy
should i go for mathematics or should i
take the actuarial examines and become
an actuary
and i'm kind of glad i didn't do the
latter because it turns out that that
was a really great job at the time
but is being
taken over by ai at this point in time
talking with some people who actually do
do that job
um
i mean
long before i was interested in
philosophy i was a metalhead
you know
i grew up in the 1970s and 1980s and so
yeah it was i mean i also mentioned too
you know watching shows like the three
musketeers and the duelists and you know
playing swords as we used to call it
we'd get sticks and garbage can lids and
go at each other
and then you know fencing in high school
that was that was a big thing for me too
you know
you know petty crime i was part of a
group called midnight sales and services
i used to do security for them when i
was a
teenager because i was big and looked
imposing and
carried around a hatchet
in my my jacket that i think some of the
people that we were fencing stuff too
thought that was a gun of course you
know was interested in getting laid
you know
uh and uh did did you know a good bit of
that in uh
high school and you know
working and then in in in college um so
lots and lots well and i used to do arts
you know i used to work with oil pastels
and watercolors so i had lots and lots
of things that i was doing i also you
know played bass um i learned to play in
the army and then played in a few never
going anywhere bands
uh all the way through college
i still play the banjo which i i picked
up in in high school my dad's old banjo
um you know and i like good coffee like
good food um a pretty good cook so
lots and lots of things going on
all right um
puja puja where are you from and would
you come to india from here the
milwaukee area i grew up about 30 miles
west of here
on the border of delafield and wales and
would i come to india
yeah i mean i would
that would probably take a lot of doing
somebody would have to you know pay for
my travel and compensate me for the time
that i'm taking away from other things
and i don't exactly see any indian
institutes
beating down my door saying hey you have
to come here and give a talk or
something but yeah
uh arielle can you do lectures on merlot
ponte yeah i can but i don't have any
plans to do that anytime soon i mean if
you want me to do if people want me to
do lectures on particular things and
take my time away from the things that i
already have planned
they gotta commission them you know i
have standard rates i've done videos
commissioned in the past
um you know if people want to commission
me to do videos i'm i'm cool with that
you know
uh gabriel have you read exemplarist
moral theory by linda zazebski if so
what do you think nah i've read a few
things by her but i'm i'm not really
that big on on her stuff so i haven't i
don't keep up with her things
alex really enjoying reading the courage
to be by paul tillich any opinions on
that book um it was i i read it and i
haven't read it again i read it as an
undergraduate in believe it or not an
honors class
which was centered around ideas we read
like b.f skinner and we read the
communist manifesto and
the sun also rises by hemingway and what
else did we read we read camus the
plague
and
what else uh dr zhivaco we read by
pasternak
um so yeah i i read it then and and
that's when i was really into
existentialism so i was like yeah this
is cool stuff
um i never considered tillich to be
one of the great existentialists but
maybe i could be wrong i mean what you
what you read is a 20 something year old
when you read it as a 50 something year
old oftentimes you
find things that you you missed right
um
rt whitby have you ever read
giovanni mirando do you mean pico de
merondola um again back in
not elementary back in in college yes
not since then
mark what do you know about simplicius
i've just ordered a book on his take on
the end caribbean well you'd have to
order two books because that's how they
sell them
um
the uh
the uh commentary on the n caridian goes
there's one book that goes like up to
like i want to say chapter 29 and then
the other book covers the rest of it
um i think simplicious is pretty cool
he's not a stoic he's a neo-platonist
but he does explain some things in that
commentary
that epictetus kind of leaves
undetermined right
and i i think simplicious point of view
is actually quite interesting
um so you'll you'll probably enjoy it
there's also
you know like good um
[Music]
uh introduction stuff in in those
volumes if you you're getting the ones
that i'm thinking about
uh sam recently on an interview chomsky
accused
jacques lacana being a charlatan and
critiqued his theory is not empirical
should the khan's theories be
empirically grounded to be taken
seriously
uh depends on what you mean by
empirically grounded there are lacanian
psychiatrists that have been working
using his stuff for over half a century
and you know helping patients out with
it is that does that count as empirical
grounding for you i mean what does
chomsky actually read of lacan you got
to ask yourself that i don't think this
is that recent uh by the way
because he was doing that years and
years ago right
um but you always got to be careful with
this empirically grounded empirical you
got to clarify what you mean by that
especially if you're talking about
something that is inherently
complex like psychotherapy so
yeah
i mean
there's this big movement to like be
evidence-based about stuff
a lot of that evidence-based stuff when
you look at the studies as a philosopher
you're like
not sure this counts as evidence you've
got some quantification here
um you did some measurements i'm not
sure that what you did here actually
translates into something
uh all right here
marco
what do you make of the claim that you
cannot be fully virtuous without being
vegan i think it's nonsense i think you
know uh
first of all now this is not actually
addressing that claim lots of vegans are
real [ __ ] sometimes they're [ __ ]
about being vegan sometimes they're just
[ __ ] and they happen to practice
veganism as a way to compensate for
being an [ __ ] so i don't think
there's any connection between veganism
and being virtuous
causing unnecessary suffering because
it's scientifically proven we can only
eat plants cannot be virtuous says who
i mean big assumption there
and uh guess what if you're a vegan
you're still causing animal suffering
because all those fields that things are
cultivated in when you plow them up
you're hurting animals
mice
shrews the pesticides
killing insects
actually a lot of times killing the
worms and stuff like that
being a vegan does not mean avoiding
animal suffering it's a way it's a sort
of puritanism
and i i think much of the time it's
silly we can say we should move to a
more
uh plant-based diet uh we should be
conscious about the suffering that we
cause but nobody is avoiding suffering
entirely so
that's kind of a non-starter
brett are you familiar with charles uh
talia farrow i remember the name but i
don't remember anything about the guy um
cilia opinion on dostoyevsky i have many
opinions on dostoyevsky which one do you
want
uh naveen best philosophy book that gave
you different perspective on everything
i don't there isn't the best um
[Music]
i mean i've i've had a lot of philosophy
books that i've read that have changed
my perspective
very few of them
do that kind of movie thing where like
your total perspective changes it's more
like yeah you know you read something
and you're like that doesn't sound right
and then after a while you're like maybe
there's something there and then after a
while you're like oh you know if i look
at things this way that you know puts
these things in perspective and then
you're like oh wow this is actually you
know
on point and i'm putting it into my life
and it's changing how i'm viewing things
that that's more common um you know
people
people who have like rapid conversions
to things i'm usually pretty distrustful
of that
and i don't i don't think that happens a
lot in
um in philosophy so
orville finished the cyropidia recently
that is the education of cyrus why does
plato's republic get so much more
discussion than xenophon
um probably because plato wrote a lot
more than xenophon and plato
as opposed to xenophon
founded an entire school of philosophy
that the republic along with the
symposium and the phaedrus and the
timaeus was absolutely central in and
continued on for you know with a sort of
unbroken continuity for a couple hundred
years
i mean xenophon is is good
uh i like i enjoy xenophon i think he's
kind of an underrated resource
but
xenophon ain't plato you know um
that's probably the reason why right
zeno do you find the problem of
suffering evil to be a strong argument
about against god if not which argument
do you find yourself trouble getting
around
no i don't i don't find it a strong
argument against god
um i'm somebody who is you know always
sort of uh struggling with god anyway
but not not so much struggling to
believe more like you know wrestling
with god you know um i'm probably not a
good person to ask about that because
i'm probably
an outlier in philosophy
sebastian what do you think about
brandon's take on hegel and his project
of explaining language i think random is
interesting brandon is a great example
of somebody who starts out as an
analytic philosopher
and
and this is a good process the more that
he engages the primary text the more he
moves away from being just an analytic
philosopher the better the more he
becomes like a good history philosophy
person
um
i haven't read his his most recent book
uh but i did see him actually present
here at marquette university in the
aquinas lecture when the book was coming
out and i'll say you know i i think that
he's emphasizing certain aspects
of hegel's
[Music]
overall point of view and de-emphasizing
others which is perfectly fine everybody
does that by the way there's and this
isn't just with hegel this is with
secondary lit in general like you know
you're really not going to find somebody
who just sticks to the text by itself i
mean even even my half-hour hegel series
where i'm trying to be as as a
closer reader as possible i'm sure
there's like emphasis that i'm bringing
in where somebody if they looked at all
the videos they could be like yeah this
is what he's focusing on he doesn't
really talk about these things right
so i like brandon um i think he's a good
person not just to talk about hegel but
kant and other philosophers as well i
enjoy reading him
uh okay let's see here
um orville or to put it another way
machiavelli seemed to think xenophon and
the cyclopedia were much more noteworthy
than plato in the republic was he right
no i mean
uh
so what if machiavelli thought that you
know i mean other people thought
otherwise so
right
david i'm a senior majoring in
philosophy in new york city i want to
write about
per-durantism any specific arguments
related to temporal persistence that you
could send my way nope that's not not
really an area that i work in and i'm
not i have no idea what perdurantism is
i suspect that some you know little
thing that's there's like a little
group of people in analytic philosophy
that are trying to you know make fetch a
word um to paraphrase uh mean girls
um i don't i don't know what it is so
about the signs how important is it to
read ancient greek literature when
studying ancient philosophy i want to
read home resilient and odyssey but not
sure which translation to pick up any
recommendations i am not a good
recommender of translations there i
actually did a whole video about that
how important is it to read ancient
greek literature when studying ancient
philosophy sure as hell can't hurt right
i mean when you read plato for example
or you read aristotle you notice that
they are making all sorts of references
to ancient greek literature right plato
will say you know what is justice
simonides in this poem over here says it
is blah blah blah blah blah right or
socrates will whip out a quote from
homer or hessian every so often right
um there are some there are some uh
characters
that are referenced you know for example
madea you know in ancient philosophy
um
[Music]
she gets used as almost like a case
study so it's it can be quite helpful to
know um
some ancient literature and it's not
that hard to you know find it it's all
available online pretty much you know
chaos uh thoughts on charles taylor
yeah you know he's okay i'm not i'm not
big on charles taylor but
um
i'm not big on hundreds of people so
uh xenovalea any thoughts on douglas
murray no
uh toxic kolaris do you do any debates
uh people would have to pay me to do a
debate because i think debates are
usually
unproductive i'm more interested in
having discussions
debates are usually done by people you
know to score points they're not usually
in good faith
they tend to be more spectacle than
actual you know philosophical discussion
so
you know if people want to pay me to
show up and do something i'm fine doing
that
um
but
i don't seek out debates
um
all right i just skipped a little bit
uh
let's see here
you know actually i think i better like
start skipping around in part because we
got about 12 minutes left
um
why did socrates maintain wrongdoings
only happen through ignorance
that's that's the point of view that he
has you know
uh he thinks that if people actually
knew what was good for them then they
wouldn't do bad things um this by the
way is
uh sort of an extreme position and
aristotle didn't think that even the
stoics didn't entirely buy into that
there's all sorts of others as well who
didn't
um
david if i sent you a short story that i
wrote which i submitted to the new
yorker and the paris review would it
give you a quick would i give it a quick
read i don't know maybe maybe not it
depends
um
really applying for a research
opportunity but i haven't written a
dissertation or anything like that can
you suggest how to write a research
proposal no somebody in your field would
have to do that right i mean or
you know and and you would definitely
want to see like what it is for your
country i i it's not as if there's a
single way to do a research
proposal
um david fagan do you think epicurus
teaching are a good choice for modern
people uh i'm an eclectic so why not
learn some epicurus and also learn some
stoics and also learn some aristotle and
you know there is a society of epicurus
out there that you can google and find
on the net and
they have lots of resources you know you
might might find that interesting
um
let's see
juan says as a philosophy professional
any idea on how to help libraries
survive in this day and age i mean as a
philosophy professional i'd be less
likely to have ideas it'd be more like
media studies people or library science
that would actually have something to
say about that
um
all right
oh here's an interesting proposal wang
toriel i'm intrigued by by plato's ship
of state allegory do you think it would
be possible to fairly implement a
voter's ed and voting license system in
the u.s and if so could it improve
things
no
because things are so fractured and so
polarized uh that you would never get
anybody to agree upon it so
it would be it's one of those in theory
it would be great in practice it's
impossible kind of things
um
let's see here
oh galen do you have a favorite obscure
platonic dialogue something that's not
one of the eight or ten typically read
the lock ace which is about courage
definitely i think that's quite
interesting
um
a lot of back and forth about
the
confessions here
um
about the signs who are the idealist
philosophers do you have any videos on
idealism
hegel's an idealist i have 340 videos in
the half-hour hegel series um and then
maybe another 10 on hegel
otherwise so he's he's a major idealist
um
kant is sometimes considered to be an
idealist right certainly in german
idealism he's criticizing other
idealists according to kant descartes is
an idealist so i have i have videos on
descartes as well so yeah there's plenty
of plenty of them out there and this
summer i hope to shoot some stuff on
schopenhauer another great german
idealist as well
um
[Music]
let's see
christopher says do you have any tips on
starting a philosophy writing project
i'm an undergraduate freshman
and i want to write about something mark
fisher and heidegger but i don't know
how to narrow down topics well start by
doing
you know outlines and mind maps and
things like that and then
part of it would be um
you know talk to other people and see
how they can help you to narrow stuff
down
you know you don't have to boil the
ocean as they say
especially i mean even if you're doing a
dissertation you focus on that
particular
topic you don't um you don't get into uh
every single thing possible to talk
about
um
[Music]
jordan costello uh where do you stand on
free will hard determinism versus soft
if i may ask i'm a compatibilist um
we have free will that that that's
pretty evident to me we don't have free
will in the sense of like any moment we
can totally change who we are but that's
not what anyone who actually believes in
free will says
um the interesting thing is always
figuring out how how do we intersect
with the causal determinism in which we
are also free causes
so that's that's my view
uh steve schramko here's a good question
what is your position on the validity of
the pragmatist criterion of truth so i
think that the pragmatist
views on truth um the theory and the
criterion can be useful in certain
circumstances right so you could say
that pragmatism
is
pragmatically limited and and this is
the the point of view of you know
real pragmatists out there like william
james he's not saying pragmatist's view
on truth applies to everything at every
time in every way um the correspondence
theory of truth or you know viewpoint on
how things are true very useful as well
uh coherence very useful as well there
may be other things that we need to work
into there as well
uh like truth in the the the nature of
things like coming from anselm truth in
the will truth and actions
aristotle's notion of practical truth
all of those things might actually be
be fitted into there
uh tln unfortunately my university
exclusively teaches analytic philosophy
so which continental thinkers do you
think are one with someone with no
experience in continental philosophy
should start with so
you want to google
sadler analytic continental because i
gave a talk years ago about
six years back at virginia commonwealth
university
where i talked about what can analytic
and continental philosophers learn from
each other and i gave them 20 reading
recommendations for
continental philosophy so that might be
something that you want to you want to
check out
um
let's see albert says since death can
happen any day why pursue any long-term
goals why not pursue daily pleasure
what do you think is the most meaningful
full thing or the best thing for a
person to do in their day um you know
love other people
improve the world you know i mean yeah
sure we could die at any moment the idea
that because of that we shouldn't do
anything other than just like
immediately pursue immediate pleasures
that's a big stretch right i mean the
world could go to [ __ ] tomorrow
or you know the sun could swallow the
earth and it doesn't mean that the good
that we've done
suddenly becomes totally meaningless you
know
ali says thank you for your videos oh
thanks i'm glad that you enjoy them uh
let's see what else we can grab in the
last
five minutes um
oh christopher i'm presenting on
shestov's all things are possible next
week at my university philosophy club
any tips on how to present him well well
that is tough right because chest off is
like very anti-systematic all over the
map
i mean
you could like bring up some of his i
would what i would do is i would bring
up some of his his aphorisms
from that and then get people talking
about him like you know bring up the
notion of logic and morality as being
police agents and say what the hell does
this mean what's going on here and
you know actually somebody asked me
about this recently what do i do when i
like plato and aristotle
and i also like chest off do i find ways
to reconcile them you could ask yourself
chest off
what can we take from him that's that's
valuable
that would fit in with other
philosophers
i mean and chest off is a funny guy i
would i would emphasize some of the
humor and jokes in it maybe as well
um that that could be quite good
um
[Music]
what else we got here
what's the relationship between ontology
and trauma especially today with a rise
in psychoanalysis and neuroscience there
isn't a rise in psychoanalysis today as
a matter of fact psychoanalysis is in
decline as a treatment modality
the rise in the last 30 years has been
pretty much the cognitive approaches
right at least here in the states i mean
maybe it's different in europe
um
depends on what you mean by ontology
sometimes people use the word ontology
and it's a synonym for metaphysics
we can talk about the metaphysics of the
human person
trauma is very important
right
we are historical beings who develop
over time
and by the time that we start to do
philosophy and think about you know the
nature of human beings and our
relationships we're already usually
screwed up
and sometimes we we don't even know the
trauma that we've we've encountered
because it's it's been
you know sometimes we repress it a lot
of times the people who did it tell us
we better not talk about it and we
forget about it right
um and sometimes it's not recognized
and we can talk about trauma
individually we can talk about trauma in
relation to generations and groups
um i mean i i think back to like my
childhood
and the ever-present concern that
maybe you know maybe we're gonna have a
nuclear war sometime soon the fact that
when i was in high school a lot of us
didn't expect to finish high school we
expected we would probably be drafted
for a war
um
that may have been a kind of you know
weird thing about living out here in the
midwest
but um that certainly did a number and i
think about the people who are
traumatized by bullying or
you know
ostracism or stuff like that that that
plays an important role
not not in metaphysics per se like the
totality of being but the metaphysics of
the human person right
it certainly um
uh has has to do something
i see kirk o'connell pouting about uh
portrayal of cato the younger in tv and
movies i mean i don't care about
portrayal of kato
the younger in uh
tv and movies i mean that's
that's why i skipped over it because
there's there's other things to answer i
mean
what do i care about how they depict
socrates right
let's let's find another good one to go
oh c
do you enjoy montan any essays in
particular yeah i do like montan and i
was actually supposed i was going to be
doing a
um for the catherine project i was going
to be doing a tutorial on montan's
essays
unfortunately one of my colleagues
needed open-heart surgery and i had to
take over his class which was running at
the same time and i didn't have the
bandwidth to do it but i yeah i love
montant i mean what's not to love
somebody else who really likes cicero
and plutarch and has all sorts of cool
reflections on stuff you know i mean his
discussion of anger is is quite
interesting there's all sorts of cool
essays in there right
rima since you like him quite a lot
which books by mock schaeler do you
recommend most well if you want to read
his really big big book it's
formalism and non-formalism and ethics
and that's a good book
you know
um if you want something nice and short
that relates to something uh
some coming from another thinker um
rizontomont you know and like in between
it there there are like anthologies that
you can get with some of his essays that
are that are quite good as well um
[Music]
he's also got the uh what is that called
there's there's a book that he's got
specifically on empathy you know like
surveying the different um theories of
it out there like edith stein and
uh other other phenomenologists um
which is which is very good um so i
would check out those
uh
mate's thoughts on fukiyama's end of
history i mean fukuyama himself has had
to eat a lot of crow because obviously
history hasn't ended
um
his book is okay i mean i'd read it i i
would i would check it out it's well
worth
reading um it's clearly wrong on on some
things but it's thought-provoking
um
i've already passed time let's see if i
can find a good one to
go out on
[Music]
here's a good one from jordan
when reading great thinkers discuss
topics such as race or gender often with
problematical historical baggage how do
you separate the good ideas from the
ideological biases that existed at the
time
you do it
you say here's the good ideas
here's the ideological baggage
and the good ideas are not vitiated by
the historical baggage you say
wow aristotle you really are kind of a
bonehead when it comes to women and
everybody who's not greek by the way and
people who work with their hands right
and you say all right so he's clearly
wrong about this
we're not going to worry that much about
what he has to say about women
um because he's he's off unless it's
something useful where he's saying you
know the barbarians one of the signs
that they're natural slaves is that they
don't distinguish between women and
slaves
what's going on there we have to unpack
this and figure it out and i mean think
about nietzsche nietzsche says a lot of
stupid [ __ ] about women and about
everybody else right
um
it's possible for you to do the critical
work of saying
i'm going to accept these ideas these
i'm not going to
to
bother with and then sometimes there'll
be things that are kind of problematic
like you know is heidegger already a
nazi
when he's you know writing being in time
no um
but there are some things that he says
you know about like tradition and the
community where you're like well
it's not nazi but you can see how he's
going down that path
and so we got to watch out for that you
know
should we you know
take the rector speech and say oh
there's a lot of great ideas in here
probably not you know a lot of this is a
matter of like keeping perspective
and establishing priorities
and saying well we're gonna we're gonna
you know use this and this and this i
think there's a lot of people and this
is where i'll end who want their their
thinkers to be pure
who want them to be like always right
about something
or
never have any done anything wrong or
said anything wrong in their life and
this kind of goes to that guru question
that somebody was asking
earlier um they want they don't want
philosophers they want gurus and gurus
are always well i won't say this always
gurus are almost always fake
they almost never measure up to
what it is that they put themselves
forward as representing
so
maybe the problem is more with with us
and the worry about you know needing
these these figures to be really great
and you don't have to like have
everything neatly separated off and a
good philosopher bad philosopher sort of
thing maybe there's a
border zone and maybe we have to like
hash this out and talk it through from
time to time so that is a great question
to end on and i will uh
say thanks to everybody for your
questions and i'll see you next time
now i'm gonna get some lunch and then
i've got a philosophy chat for patreon
supporters to get to
and i'll see you next time